said the word legend is used to
frequently in modern-day sport but for
Seve Ballesteros it seems hardly
sufficient the swashbuckling Spaniard
won five majors in a glittering career
and made the world take notice of
European golf
it didn't surprise me because I expected
I'd be slicing a dream about that at the
Spanish Open in Barcelona the flags are
now flying at half-mast and the players
are due to wear black ribbons as the
game remembers one of its greats
Ballesteros honed his skills on the
courses fields and beaches of northern
Spain his raw talent an immense belief
proving to be a magical mix in 1976 at
the age of 19 he was runner-up in the
open and amazing achievement for the
relatively unknown teenager who would go
on to become a household name if he
walked into a room the whole atmosphere
changed it was intense everything he had
was a brooding intensity he he went at
everything as if his life's passion to
do that and so he would you know he
would never say die his way of playing
golf was phenomenal but everything could
be done nothing was impossible
Ballesteros is success helped put
European golf where it is now and the
way he won Ryder Cup matches in
particular inspired many of today's top
professionals he certainly had an impact
on the game but to me the greatest thing
about SEVIS is his flair and his
charisma because of the way he played
the golf played the game of golf you
were drawn to him you wanted to go watch
him play he had charisma and he just
kind of had so many shots that it was
fun fun to watch him play Seve
Ballesteros fought cancer with the same
passion and determination he showed up
Holland's on the golf course he'll be
remembered as a superstar on the
fairways and a gentleman of them